now I'm just gonna make a big deal out
of this because it's kind of it feels
like a technicality but it said do you
understand what's going on do you see
how these complex numbers work okay
a lot of you said okay modulus that's
fine I can do modulus pretty much
everyone like I said got to okay but
there people went to here they said ox
and equals and then they said oh cool I
know the way I remember this auxilary
angle right I just want an angle so I'll
go tan inverse of one on Route three
right well actually it's minus one a
minus root three okay but that's kind of
the problem right because you can see
here tan inverse traits minus one on
minus root three it treats it exactly
the same as positive one on positive
root three okay so where's this guy this
guy's in the first quadrant that's where
you get your PI on six frosting okay but
this is not in the first quadrant it's
in the third quadrant which is very easy
to see and this is what I mean by
understanding right like the second you
see this your brain should do sorry
minus root three that right and so you
should have noted like this is
ridiculous right how can you write this
down and not know that something has
gone wrong okay
so this is what I mean by like math is
not just about it's a series of
algorithms you crunch through them and
then you get an answer at the end right
do you know why the algorithm does what
it does okay
in exactly the same way where I'll
answer in Quadrant two you are in
Quadrant four again tendinous doesn't
care right it'll treat negative and
positive as the same as positive or
negative okay so that's why at any of us
be careful with it it's a great tool but
you need to learn to use it properly
which is why we get to the whole topic
on inverse trigonometric functions okay
and it's a dangerous tool you have to
use carefully as was imported by this
okay so please don't ever ever ever
anymore use tan in us to find the
argument of complex number it's
completely insufficient okay some of you
did try to correct right by saying oh I
got PI on six but I know because maybe I
skipped our rough diagram but that's
actually the base angle so then you
kinda redeemed yourself and said okay
I actually know where it's supposed to
be but you had this problem having said
from the first place right I'd say this
pi16 but it's not right don't find the
wrong answer and then fix it up just
find the pine answer in the first place
do you see what I mean okay it's not
just a technicality
I don't like ten inverse okay it's a tan
inverse compromises your answer okay
let's move on to read further once you
got that again it was pretty
straightforward there's our there's our
what our form right there oh just
another minor thing too many people too
many people writing that okay - five
point six that's the whole argument okay
so please don't be lazy on that lots of
people trip up themselves by not being
able to read their own writing just
don't do it okay like it doesn't take
that much imagination to imagine this
turning in a hurry into this which turns
into this like come on you're in a hurry
right don't don't do that to yourself
that's in bracket all right now
tomorrow's theorem here we go you just
have to use it you should stay it's by
de maras there it comes from somewhere
don't just write that that's the case
because actually that's a very profound
result then you can just multiply the
laws and add the odds and do it to
whatever multiple okay you guys were
lucky I
she's a marking sort of tip in the
future have you gotten this is your
first answer okay you would have gone
ahead and you would have gotten
something actually not that far off okay
I'm you're off by you're off by this
rotation okay so you end up getting I
think -16 root 3 plus 69 or something
comprable of that okay so you're not
completely wrong and technically you
have a carried forward month however
okay if you went ahead and you did pine
six when you need to - ooh do you see
you actually get something easier than
what I had to deal with and what the
people who did the question right had to
deal with okay so you were guys you guys
were grandidis for actually having not
two marks for you got the right answer
from the wrong solution the wrong
earlier part but I could have actually
dr. mark there if I wanted to because
you simplified the question again I
chose not to because I didn't want you
to feel like I lost marks on technique
these every mark lost was a real mark
not like some of all hafsat religion
about half mark but the market was like
angry or something like that
every mark was really worth it and every
month it was lost was really worth it so
you got lucky if you carried this on
from part one and you got you two